we will now consider an example that
illustrates the difference between the
notion of independence of a collection
of events and the notion of pairwise
independence within that collection the
model is simple we have a fair coin
which we flip twice so at each flip
there is probability 1/2 of obtaining
hands furthermore we assume that the two
flips are independent of each other
let h1 be the event that the first coin
toss resulted in heads which corresponds
to this event in this diagram let H to
be the event that the second toss
resulted in heads which is this event in
the diagram the two ways that we can
have the second toss being hands now
we're assuming that the tosses are
independent so the event heads head has
a probability which is equal to the
probability that the first toss resulted
in heads that's one-half times the
probability that the second toss
resulted in heads which is one-half so
the product is 1/4 we have probability
1/4 for this outcome now the total
probability of event h1 is one-half
which means that the probability of what
remains should be 1/4 so that the sum of
these two numbers is one-half by the
same argument the probability of this
outcome tails heads should be 1/4 we
have a total of 3/4 so what's left is
1/4 and that's going to be the
probability of the outcome tails tails
let us now introduce a new event namely
the event that the two tosses had the
same result so this is the event that we
obtain either heads heads or tails tails
schematically event C corresponds to
this blue region in the diagram is event
C independent from the events h1 and h2
let us first look for pairwise
independence let's look at the
probability that H 1 occurs and C occurs
as well so the first toss resulted in
heads and the two tosses had the same
result so this is the same as the
probability of obtaining heads followed
by heads and this corresponds to just
this outcome that has probability 1/4
how about the product of the
probabilities of h1 and of C is it the
same well the probability of H 1 is 1/2
and the probability of C what is it
event C consists of two outcomes each
one of these outcomes has probability
1/4 so the total is again 1/2 and
therefore the product of these
probabilities is 1/4 so we notice that
the probability of the two events
happening is the same as the product of
their individual probabilities and
therefore h1 and C are independent
events by the same argument h2 and C are
going to be independent it's a
symmetrical situation h1 and h2 are also
independent from each other so we have
all the conditions for pairwise
independence let us now check whether we
have independence to check for
independence we need to also look into
the probability of all three events
happening and see whether it is equal to
the product of the individual
probabilities so the probability of all
three events happening this is the
probability that
Schwann occurs and h2 occurs and c
occurs what is this event heads in the
first toss heads in the second toss and
the two tosses are the same this happens
if and only if the outcome is heads
followed by heads and this has
probability 1/4 on the other hand if we
calculate the probability of H 1 times
the probability of H 2 times the
probability of C we get 1/2 times 1/2
times 1/2 which is 1/8 these two numbers
are different and therefore one of the
conditions that we have for Independence
is violated so in this example H 1 H 2
and C are pairwise independent but they
are not independent in the sense of an
independent collection of events how are
we to understand this intuitively if I
tell you that event H 1 occurred and I
ask you for the conditional probability
of C given that H 1 what is this this is
the probability that we obtain given
that the first event is heads the first
result is heads the only way that you
can have the two tosses having the same
result is going to be if the second toss
also results in heads and since H 2 and
H 1 are independent this is just the
probability that we have heads in the
second toss and this number is 1/2 and
1/2 is also the same as the probability
of C that's another way of understanding
the independence of H 1 and C given that
the first toss resulted in heads this
does not help you in any way
in guessing whether the two tosses will
have the same result or not the first
one had was heads but the second one
could be either heads or tails with
equal probability so event h1 does not
carry any useful information about the
occurrence or non-occurrence of event c
on the other hand if I were to tell you
that both events h1 and h2 happened what
would the conditional probability of C
be if both h1 and h2 occur then the
results of the two coin tosses were
identical so you know that C also
occurred so this probability is equal to
1 and this number 1 is different than
from the unconditional probability of C
which is 1/2 so we have here a situation
where knowledge of h1 having occurred
does not help you in making a better
guess on whether C is going to occur h1
by itself does not carry any useful
information but the two events together
h1 and and h2 do carry useful
information about C once you know that
h1 and h2 occurred then C is certain to
occur so your original probability for C
which was 1/2 now get revised to a value
of 1 so h1 and h2 carry information
relevant to C and therefore C is not
independent from these two events
collectively and we say that events h1
h2 and C are not independent